why does time pass it is a question so
profound that few people would even
think to ask it yet its effects are all
around human beings live in a perpetual
present inexorably sealed off from the
past but moving relentlessly into the
future for most people time seems to be
something that is just out there a thing
ticking away in the background fixed
immutable
time seems to go in one direction in one
direction only but physicists see it
much differently
John Archibald wheeler said time is what
stops everything from happening at once
I wish I could explain what it would be
like for there not to be time but I
can't we experience time we are
psychological creatures that have time
and that's kind of one of our defining
characteristics so if time weren't
around we don't really have even a good
way to describe what happens because
happens right that's a verb right there
that has to do with time so I think once
you start wondering about this you get
much further into the realms of
philosophy than physics I actually don't
think it's that mysterious we live in a
world that's full of stuff and this
world happens over and over again with
the stuff in slightly different
positions time is just the label on all
those different moments that constitute
the history of the universe it's very
much like the page numbers in a book one
of the great minds who changed the way
science thinks about time was Albert
Einstein in 1905 he published his
special theory of relativity which
described the motion of objects moving
near the speed of light in it he
demonstrated that time passes
differently in different places
depending on how those places are moving
with respect to one another
so first I'm Stein studied the effect of
fast motion and he found that space and
time got mixed up if you moved more
quickly and that's his special theory of
relativity the theory of relativity is
so called because even the difference
between time and space is relative to
what observer is doing the measuring in
particular to how fast you're moving
this is something that we never notice
in our everyday lives but once you start
moving close to the speed of light
relativity becomes crucial Einstein
showed that the faster one travels the
slower time goes for the traveler at the
speeds at which humans move this is
imperceptible but for someone traveling
on a spaceship at speeds close to that
of light time would slow down compared
with its passage for people on earth one
of Einstein's great insights was to
understand
that different people moving at
different speeds through the universe
see different events as being
simultaneous there was another important
aspect of Einstein's theory which he
didn't even realize when he published it
the time was woven into the very fabric
of space itself it was actually not line
Stein but another German mathematician
named Hermann Minkowski who pointed out
that Einstein's theory could be thought
of as a theory of a single
four-dimensional space-time and I signed
when he first heard this idea said well
that's just a mathematician talking
that's not really something that is very
useful to physicists but once he tried
to fit gravity into his theory of
relativity he realized the space-time
concept was crucial
Einstein used this insight to help
develop his general theory of relativity
which incorporated gravity he published
it in 1915 ten years after his special
theory of relativity which was focused
solely on motion Einstein tried very
hard he worked for ten years after
inventing special relativity to fit
gravity into the framework and
eventually he realized he needed a new
framework so he invented what we call
the general theory of relativity where
Einstein says that this space-time stuff
this four-dimensional world in which we
live has a life of its own
space-time itself can move it has
dynamics it has curvature and it's that
curvature that geometry of space-time
that you and I experienced as the force
of gravity and then he found the time
was also changed by your proximity to a
very massive object so like a black hole
is the best example but also just how
close we are to the earth or to the Sun
or anything else that has a
gravitational field changes the passage
of time with the general theory of
relativity he demonstrated that massive
objects warped the fabric of space-time
it is this curvature that causes time to
slow down near them accordian general
agility time slows down near massive
bodies it slows down any place that
gravity pulls you tour
time slows down in proportion to the
gravitational pull of a nearby object so
the effect would be strong near a black
hole but milder near the earth but even
here it can be detected Einstein's
theories had to be taken into account
when the GPS system was set up otherwise
it would have been inaccurate these
ideas about space and time being
relative sound very wild and far out and
removed for everyday experience but to
physicist they are very very important
there's something we observe every day
one of the interesting things about
Einstein's equations is that none of
them suggest time goes in only one
direction they work equally well if time
goes forwards or backwards this is in
contrast to everyday experience one of
the conundrums is that the laws of
physics for the most part do not
distinguish between time going forward
and time going backwards and yet the
actual world that we experience
certainly is different forward to
backwards one scientist who puzzled over
the directionality of time was Arthur
Eddington a 20th century astronomer who
defined the concept of the arrow of time
based on observations made by the 19th
century physicist Ludwig Boltzmann in
space there's no preferred direction
there's no difference in the laws of
physics if you look left or look right
but there seems to be an enormous
difference between the past and the
future that's what we call the arrow of
time and it's a little bit mysterious
why is the past so different from the
future we think it's not a difference in
the deep down fundamental laws of
physics it's actually just a difference
because of the universe in which we live
the arrow of time is just time as we
experience one second following one
other second following another second
it's just the x psychological experience
of time and the fact that things change
as we experience them but it seemed to
happen in the world forward so buildings
get built but they decay slowly and it's
that decay there's at least partially
responsible for the arrow of time it's
the increase of entropy so in
thermodynamics we know that things get
more random over time and that appears
to be very fundamental to our experience
of time
and what's happening in the universe the
arrow of time is based on the second law
of thermodynamics which says the
disorder known as entropy increases with
time for example a building left
untouched will slowly decay into its
surroundings it will disintegrate into a
more chaotic state but it is highly
unlikely that the building will become
more orderly over time this is because
there are many more ways for a system to
be disorderly than orderly there can be
many ways for something to break for
instance but only one way for it to be
put back together again a system will be
less disordered in the past and more
disordered in the future this is the
arrow of time so how can the arrow of
time be reconciled with Einstein's
equations if time can go forwards and
backwards according to relativity does
that mean it's possible to go backwards
in time we actually don't know whether
it's possible to travel backwards in
time we do know it's possible to travel
forwards yesterday I travel forwards 24
hours and Here I am right now you can't
help but travel forward in time our best
guess is that you just can't travel
backward in time the theory of
relativity does allow time travel to the
future if I go down near a black hole
and stay there for one hour
you may go forward by seven years by the
time I come back so you've moved forward
in time seven years while I move forward
in time just one hour
Einstein's theories do allow for the
formation of wormholes in space these
are shortcuts that link otherwise
distant places in the space-time
continuum so a wormhole is a hole in
space and time that comes out somewhere
else and it does it much faster than the
speed of light potentially so it would
be a way of violating what we think of
otherwise as a fundamental speed limit
in Einstein's theories and it does it in
a way that doesn't obviously violate
Einstein's theories but we're not sure
that there's any actual way you can
build a wormhole they might be shut off
from the rest of space and time and so
could never actually use it to do
anything although wormholes are
theoretically possible they're a highly
implausible proposition that's because
the equations suggest enormous masses
and energies would be required to create
and manipulate one there are two
problems of the wormholes one is if you
don't have one how you create it and the
other is if you do have one how do you
hold it open so it doesn't collapse and
prevent you from going through and in
both cases what we understand about
these questions points toward a
conclusion that wormholes are probably
forbidden by the laws of nature
what remains then is a mystery theory
fails to forbid traveling backwards in
time but practice suggests it might just
as well be forbidden for now it would
appear the arrow of time cannot be
reversed no one knows why time passes
but it seems that no matter how people
look at it it goes in one direction in
one direction only
you